[Music]
i've been in a bad mood all week so you
want to know what i've been doing
healthily processing your feelings no
when i'm in a bad mood i do the exact
opposite instead of processing my
feelings in a healthy way i focus
all of my anger on a trivial thing in
the past
one thing that i can do nothing about
how does that work
i'll show you right now in a segment
called being mad like it's 1993.
[Music]
this is angela bassett i think about her
a lot
she didn't deserve what happened to her
and i'm mad about it
in 1993 she was the star of the tina
turner biopic what's love got to do with
it
in the film she plays icon tina turner
in a story that followed her journey
from
a young girl to a superstar she gave a
superb
performance people said bassett is a
genius
she is sheer black excellence i wish
she was my blood relative i'm people i
said those things
but critics agreed and she won a golden
globe
the movie has a 96 percent on rotten
tomatoes
and she was nominated for an academy
award and what are you mad about
i'm mad she didn't win did you not hear
what i said earlier
i said i focus my anger on a trivial
thing
angela bassett has transcended any award
in my opinion and
winning does not dictate her worth but i
still will present my argument with the
passion and anger meant for the far
bigger thing i am avoiding
understood continue on my sister angela
bassett did not win the oscar in 1993
instead it was given to holly hunter for
her performance in the piano
but in that movie didn't holly hunter
play a woman who doesn't talk
she did i'm understanding your anger
more and more
do you know why she didn't talk why
because she would have surely said
this is boring she wouldn't ask her for
boring me to pieces
so you saw i want to know the piano
the commercials derek i was bored by the
commercials
let's compare the two movies shall we
for what's love got to do with it angela
bassett had to learn how to talk like
tina
how to walk like tina and how to dance
like tina
holly hunter just had to learn how to
look sad on a beach
something we've all done when have you
been sad on the beach
i dropped my sandwich in the sand but
kept eating it and now that's something
i have to know about myself
angela bassett gave us music like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
holly hunter gave us music like this
[Music]
angela bassett gave us this look and
this look
and this look holly hunter gave us this
look
angela bassett's portrayal of the
domestic abuse and violence that tina
turner experienced was visceral and at
times hard to watch
i feel like just based on the sheer
amount of physicality
she should have won an oscar and if you
see
that movie you know that they should
have also thrown in an olympic medal for
track
as well
[Music]
and a frogger award for dodging cars
[Applause]
why are they playing lethal weapon music
but she is really running she's really
running for really running they didn't
tell her
that no and those cars i i realize that
the movie and it's all
choreographed but i thought she was
going to die so did she
and what's love got to do with it should
have also won a megan the stallion body
audio award for this
tina turner body adiotie
a deltoid has never been more deserving
of an oscar
but seriously if you have not seen this
film i highly recommend it
i think it's an amazing piece of film
history
also a perfect parallel to life angela
bassett had to literally
dance circles around the other girls you
know what angela bassett
had to literally run circles around the
other girls can we see that clip one
more time
[Applause]
she's running in a straight line but it
looks like she's kind of like
falling down
it was hard work is what i'm saying
angela bassett had to literally dance
circles around
the other girls on top of giving a
gut-wrenching performance and
still didn't get what she deserved which
makes it a perfect place to focus my
anger
because why be mad at the things that
happen in 2020
when i can be mad like it's 1993.
[Music]
[Applause]
you